bonjour bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale
télé spéciale championnat du monde
allant de topalov le big match avec
qu'aujourd'hui pour commenter la
quatrième partie de l'affrontement entre
les champions nous recevons philippe
d'horme bush savait philippe rey bonjour
stéphane et merci encore de me recevoir
sur le plateau de diagonale tv c'est
toujours un plaisir de l'anr alors nous
c'est évidemment le plaisir de recevoir
le webmaster de thiès et stratégies le
site qui fait le buzz et chicken
évidemment ouais donc
incite d'ailleurs qui se mit à jour par
là j'ai vu il ya de plus en plus
d'annonceurs en fait sur ce see donc à
une vraie demande
oui en fait bon il ya trois quatre
billets nouveau tous les tous les jours
donc ce qui fait pas mal d'audience et
derrière quelques annonceurs qui
viennent donc promouvoir leurs produits
et même des livres des chèques
aujourd'hui en fait les nations
maintenant la voilà la nouveauté 2010
c'est le lancement de la boutique avec
et en partenariat avec amazon amazon.fr
cette offre merci un contrat
international voilà exactement 1 pour
les droits et puis on a on propose alors
une sélection de livres
évidemment qu'on a lu et qui sont les
meilleurs selon nous pour progresser aux
échecs
toujours avec m
alors nous avons maîtres fous ni
admettre vous d'as dans l'équipe voilà
qui est toujours actif
voilà toujours toujours actif ça y est
toujours bien sûr et puis nous avons en
fait deux trois spécialistes du jeu 2002
2003 100 lots 1 qui nous disent ah bah
voilà nous moi j'ai lu tel livre il est
intéressant donc on le relit et puis on
regarde un petit peu s'il est assez
pédagogique parce que je cherchais cette
stratégie en fait notre objectif en fait
c'est de dire à nos lecteurs attention
ce livre est bien fait parce que il a un
certain niveau mais aussi parce qu'il
explique bien les choses ainsi et pour
les habitants notamment ou pour les pour
les voilages veulent apprendre plus et
qui veulent progresser exactement
stéphane voilà c'est un peu la
philosophie donc le lancement a eu lieu
en janvier 2010 de cette bibliothèque
librairie en ligne bio tech alors il ya
aussi évidemment toujours la musique
surtout stratégique c'est ce qui a fait
le charme de dividendes reims et de
pouvoir en même temps appréciée du jazz
beaucoup de jazz
oui mais donc toujours associé le jeu
d'échecs à tout ce qui est au beau fun
et sympathique comme le jeu lui-même
l'ouvrir à disons aux loisirs au sens
large à se concentrer uniquement sur
l'aspect purement et chic et voilà
cécile suffisent tout ce qui est autour
ce qui gravite autour ce qui ce qui est
assez culturel quand même mais on peut y
trouver donc du cinéma de la musique
alors de la littérature de la
littérature et gilles pas forcément
l'échiquier mais souvent avec un rapport
au jeu d'échecs puisqu'on sait que dans
l'univers du jeu et de très bons livres
mais aussi dès maintenant des quizz donc
qu'elle plie aussi chaque fois la
mélodie me semble on mardi je ne sais
plus où on en est au café
alors on a le café si on a le mercredi
les toits de la question people du nord
croit dit oui mais avec un café ou faire
alors c'était voilà un café offerts à
bas régulièrement notre 1 du no
consultant cet instant en fait un
photographe professionnel
charlie morale à charlie qui offrent le
café et charlie voilà on a aussi en fait
le rendez vous en deux en dehors du
rendez vous du mercredi traditionnel
depuis le départ on a un premier rendez
vous de début de semaine le mardi avec
un maître international et je profite
pour le saluer marc et berthe
oui un qui me fait assez gras 116 à
l'est le sa lettre hpe 1 et berck par
l'échec alors là ça s'adresse à des
joueurs d'un très bon niveau il voit
l'avenir c'est vraiment pour le top du
top
voilà
voilà on a donc le mercredi la question
people et puis le jeudi tous les jeudis
la chronique en fait de samir samir a
dit elle que je remercie aussi au
passage qui publie une chronique dans le
paris normandie tous les mercredis et
puis donc alors et il n'ya permettre de
la republier le coup de chroniques
spécialisée avec des intervenants et
allons donc maintenant aussi la boutique
je dirais vêtements donc alors oui il
ferait de chelsea stratégie logo teese
est effectivement alors
le logo vous le reconnaissez si vous
êtes lecteur habitué donc tout le monde
des vêtements ou c'est juste pour
l'instant un lancement je dirais
promotionnels c'est ça que tu vas
supporter les joueurs et dieu alors
voilà ils vont porter les couleurs de
lecce stratégie exactement alors c'est
la première phase en fait on à 2005 et
jeux exactement on a contacté des très
bons joueurs et des jeunes
préférentiellement et on a en fait deux
joueurs on va dire de la dream team qui
porte les vêtements tags et jesse et
stratégie il s'agit de maxime lagarde
qui est un jeune maître international
bientôt un des grands espoirs français
un grand z très très bon voilà un très
fort joueur
et puis on a évidemment que ces
stratégies sans les femmes ne seraient
pas toucher à ces stratégies on à
aurélie dacalor un kit borné sur la
grippe chez tran huy mesure où c'est le
grand plaisir c'est extrêmement griffé
alors annonce topalov n'est pas encore
griffe est cecce stratégie mais mais
un petit peu des banalités et puisqu'on
avait retransmis cramique kasparov et un
en date a gagné son titre en battant
cramique donc de loin en 2008 déjà
oui bakhtaoui il a battu un grammy mais
nous on avait fillon n'a évidemment
diffusé en 2000 le grand match donc ya
pas un lien direct mais indirects alors
donc il n'est pas griffé on n'y a pas
d'enfant nos conditions alors ce match
oui à nantes au palau est ce que tu as
un favori oui alors je vais peut-être
surprendre du monde en disant que
topaloff est mon favori
alors pourquoi en fait j'aime le jeu
topalov parce que c'est un jeu très
dynamique n'est sûr très agressif c'est
très agressif et puis l'homme aussi est
vraiment on va dire à la recherche
constante d'activité sur l'échiquier le
moindre micro avantages et bae est
décelé il essaie toujours de convertir
sa pour faire avancer faire progresser
en fait c'est pierre ancel feel that a
donc voilà c'est vrai que les parties de
tableau ce sont quasiment tout le temps
spectaculaire est alors celle des
joueurs du circuit qui financent ces
partis au bout il ya eu effectivement
écrit il fait qu'aucune en fait aucune
nul de complaisance
donc voilà alors il a été souvent
remarqué comme étant l'un des seuls
joueurs du circuit à rester assis
pendant les 4 à 6 heures de la partie
pourra chercher à améliorer ses
positions et même dans les dé je dirais
même dans la défaite il est
spectaculaire
parce que si tu te souviens bien
stéphane la partie la meilleure partie
du jeu d'échecs
en fait elle a été découverte un jour
c'était celle entre kasparov et topalov
en 1999
noyer donc c'est la partie primés comme
avec un double sacrifice de tours dans
le sens et à la meinau
c'est une mémoire avec un double
sacrifice qu'il réalise est magnifique
et qui a été primé comme la partie la
meilleure partie de l'histoire des
échecs pour les spécialistes on pourrait
citer aussi une partie entre shirov et
topalov ou encore une fois topalov a
perdu mais de manière magnifique sur une
idée en finale de shirov un sacrifice de
fou un fou en achète elle qui a permis
au roi en fait en finale de gagner un
temps et de gagner la partie en juste en
décalant fait l'adversaire d'une carafe
exactement en décalant d'une case donc
je dirais pourquoi topaloff est mon
favori parce que même dans la défaite
il est magnifique et mène là un sens
estate en tout cas tu es fan du jeu
spectaculaire de total où exactement on
s'ennuie pas avec thomas l'or avec un
temps on a aussi un joueur magnifique
c'est un des joueurs évidemment qui en
rend débute sa carrière jouer le plus
vite on l'appelait lucky luke eu des
échecs alors c'est vrai et c'est tu
pourquoi
en fait ils jouaient si vite mais parce
qu'ils lui mais d'expliquer tout
simplement qu'il voyait pas pourquoi il
y avait il fallait réfléchir qui voit là
tout de suite moins cher et intuitif
j'ai eu une explication parce que quand
il jouait en inde
il y avait très peu de matériel et les
enfants jouer
avec un seul jeu et donc il devait céder
la place très rapidement donc la demande
et les enfants devient vite donc il a
pris c'est la légende qui raconte ça il
a pris l'habitude de jouer vite c'est
parti ouais mais depuis il s'est assagi
oui mais cette fois maintenant la ligue
joue un peu comme les autres
c'est-à-dire que il prend tout son temps
il a même perdu une fois autant contre
kamski ce qui était la première fois
rien en face arrière un derrick
il est maintenant classique mais c'est
un effectivement c'est un champion du
monde comme topalov d'ailleurs à à
suivre vraiment très fort joueur alors à
ce moment du match où on arrive
aujourd'hui
oui on est à la quatrième partie par
tous donc il s'est fait surprendre le
nom de la première magnifique partie de
topalov sacrifice de cavaliers malheur
sur un jeu quand même un peu curieux
d'un an bien que oui
enfin bref c'est douteux bouaye et par
aussi très vite repris un an dans la
deuxième avec une très belle catalane
superbe et troisième parties nu avec
dans le rôle des noirs qui finalement
change joue plus la brune fait du coup
il a plus joué la joue là cela est
solide très solide il est au palm n'est
pas réussi à passer ça pour avoir ça
pour la suite
oui hélas allant de nous voiler blanc et
on va voir cette partie c'est parti
quatrième du match
annan le fasse à topalov avec philippe
de ces stratégies qui nous accompagne
aujourd'hui sur pato de la monaque tv on
y va avec des quatre cavaliers m6 c4est
aussi voilà donc topalov montre la
couleur il joue le coup ici peu 6 voilà
et donc il veut sortir son fouet fuite
souvent un b 4 avec un petit échec au
passage qui parfois des pertuis ou un
peu les blancs on va voir comment ça se
déroule donc cavalier f3 d'essai voilà
donc là il choisit de pages où il faut
des 4 mai de jouer dessin est donc
simple pour l'instant quelque chose qui
peut ressembler à un candidat
par exemple s'il est blanc joue cavalier
c3 où exactement mais non à nous de
choisir g3 alors ça c'est un c'est la
catalane donc les blancs de le sortir le
front j'ai de vie dans le problème c'est
que le pion c4 ne saura plus évidemment
repro nabeul du fou donc ce qui peut
être un sacrifice mais un échange de
quoi les dents de scie les noirs
prennent en c4 les blancs une très belle
action sur cette grande et von ah ben
voilà c'est exactement le thème de la
catalane à un stéphane que tu cette
ligne là donc on donne un pion avec les
blancs pour une activité des pièces un
développement supérieur des pièces
blanches c'est d'ailleurs ce que fait au
pâlot alors à noter que cette ouverture
catalanes rouges et de on valide et donc
foulé quatre échecs toujours classe y
voilà ce qu'on peut dire ici c'est qu'il
ya une peu un petit changement par
rapport à la
la partie catalan précédente où on avait
vu un à six oui aussi quelques coups
voilà donc la donc topalov varie
puisqu'il a perdu la première partie va
changer un petit peu son plan dont qui
joue toujours dans la même idée de la
catalane mais fou fou b4 il vous faut
des quatre échecs alors à noter que se
fout des quatre échecs ici en face est
catalan pardon je retrouve cette catala
et telles armes choisies par cramique
quand il a battu topalov justement oui
alors c'est vrai que c'est quand même ça
c'est important ça c'est un facteur
psychologique important disait 'je c'est
un facteur psychologique on peut dire
c'est vrai que ben ramener qui était un
joueur de tête à l'année parce que c'est
l'un des seuls joueurs à savoir
temporiser même avec les noirs quand il
joue même contre une catalane et ce qui
est difficile un porto pas l'offre
puisque on l'a dit tout à l'heure c'est
un joueur dynamique avec l'attaquant
voilà donc je pense que la légaux de
topalov
réapparaissent à dire qu'il ne va
montrer il va essayer de montrer qu'il
est capable de jouer tout un donc même
les partis un peu resserré pour les
noirs tout à fait on va voir ça donc un
fou des doux dingues logique quoi il
parle et blanc à 5 alors ça c'est un
coût original connu une amende mais
original au lieu d'enlever le on aurait
pu enlever le four on aurait pu les
changer aussi pourquoi pas mais je n'en
aurais pu l'enlever mais on joue à c'est
avec l'idée que si les blancs prennent
en b4 évidemment on a un super pions en
beckham qui vient on a deux pions ici
très fort en plus on peut protéger et la
torah vite qu'à une très belle action du
coup voilà donc devient très dynamique
effectivement les changes n'est pas
intéressant échange intéressant et si
c'est pour pousser les blancs a joué à
troyes dont s'affaiblir un petit peu de
ce côté là parce que je joue à trois on
affaiblit ces cases blanches mais
actuellement on fait des trous l'ont
fait des trous donc toujours intéressant
donc dame ces deux tranquille donc
développement normal de la part des
blancs la mc2 ben je vise simplement
c'est très simple le le pion ces cas tu
vas falloir que je le récupère un jour
ou l'autre
quand même voilà je contrôle au passage
la 15e 4 qui est une case clé dans la
vienne toujours c'est bien sûr qu'à
centrale clé puisque je peux aussi jouer
que 4,5
voilà exactement bien sûr alors on y va
fonder deux langues c'est le moment que
choisit topalov pour prôner de est alors
avec l'idée que ben finalement il est
heureux c'est de dire bombay s'est pas
forcément la meilleur casque aux
cavaliers bien de prendre l'un d'eux
puisque ben on en voit simplement coup
suivant un an même si ses joueurs
évidemment cavaliers prendre des points
des deux ça finit de développement mais
alain dejoux un autre coup qui paraît
plus curieux il fait d'un de pro d2 oui
oui parce qu'il a prévu quelque chose
qu'on va voir au 10e coup une nouveauté
dans la loire tient donc ses il joue sa
préparation mais sa passion voilà donc
là on est dans quelque chose de
volontairement surprenant pour
l'adversaire c'est ce qu'on appelle une
préparation réparation théorie tard et
d'ailleurs on a vu un
la partie les coûts des filets en fait
dans la partie joue très très vite et
bien sûr ils connaissent tout net tout
est préparé jusqu'à ce niveau là c'est 6
à 4 donc on veut empêcher les vaisselles
qu'on veut pouvoir par exemple jouer
cavalier à 3 et 4 ans et 4 c'est ça
l'idée de solidarité on en a quatre
alors je me plais cinq ans même avec les
noirs alors évidemment on n'a pas peur
de là alors on n'a pas peur si on devra
quand même avoir tant faut toujours
avoir un peu peur mais on n'a pas fait
rire de apprendre b5 s'éprend b5 puisque
sur cavaliers ou cinq qui est
intéressant quand même qu'il faut quand
même regarder on attaque la fois mythe
n'est sûr mais maintenant qu'on a joué à
cinq évidemment la tour peut venir voilà
tranquillement les autres variantes on
l'entouré souhait prise de la ricine
mais là on peut simplement je tour à
sept et même en plus il vient d'avoir la
tour là puisqu'elle peut revenir au sein
de soit 1,7 soit des fois en dix-sept
une fois que exactement avec une bonne
activité donc non on fais pas ça sur bc
on joue simplement car il ya trois très
intéressant voilà la nouveauté pression
voit la pression sur la le pion b5
on vise en fait les dames en fait les
pions qui sont assez avancés et puis on
a toujours en réserve
bah le fou angers de la lecavalier qui
va bondir comme tu te montre très bien à
l'écran en 5 et ça ça peut déstabiliser
complètement la dame des noirs alors
voilà c'est ça l'idée cercueil blanc en
fait voilà le voilà une idée dans lequel
les blancs riches a mené les noirs ils
ont fait avancer ses pions dans les ses
pions sont quand même très avancé l'idée
de ses pions avancé c'est simplement que
regarder ici on a une cible ce qu'on
appelle une cible donc ici à 4 on a une
cible
cavalier ou cinq on aura une cible en c6
et si les noirs jouent soit b4 soit
avait prend 1,4 mais tous les pions
deviennent des cibles ce qu'ils
deviennent faibles en fait et on peut
faire très vite un ce genre de point on
peut perdre très vite ce genre de
position en se faisant défaut mais tous
les pions essayer les blancs avec un
gros pions plus donc là attention il
faut jouer de manière très
précautionneuse côté noir tout à fait
donc fou 17 cavaliers seuls cavaliers
c'est normal car voilà donc on en
profite al'avantage alors pourquoi les
noirs ont pas peur de 4 quand même six
attaques locales et bien sa bouche le
fou l'ours a un avantage ni inconvénient
l'avantagé c'est que ça contre le bien
le centre le désavantage c'est que le
fou du g2 est bouché voile a
momentanément bloqué bien sûr alors fou
b4 donc à l'évêque alors le cavalier
voilà donc ça c'est bien puisqu'ils
viennent sur une belle kazan b4 ici mais
on voit bien que là maintenant il ya des
problèmes il va former pour l'attendre
et le football est bloquée donc si on
prend reprise bay
il n'y a pas de n'y a pas d' attaques de
tours james annoncé un ca t1 côté noir
activement stéphane donc pour l'instant
petit rock mais les noirs peuvent rien
faire on peut pas prendre a pas prendre
à 4 pourquoi parce que ces cas tombe
ensuite à c'est à 4 est faible puisque
la tour l'attaqué est difficile à
défendre à 5 fm qui derrière ses six est
faible si on prend à 4 comme ça on va
subjectivement avant des problèmes c'est
pas c'est pas le moment de le faire
donc là on va plutôt procéder à au petit
rock des deux côtés pour mettre le roi à
l'abri et dynamiser un peu les pièces
qui reste à sortir notamment on voit le
cavalier b8 des noirs qui pour l'instant
n'a pas joué donc il va falloir lui
trouver quelque chose à une activité ce
qui est parce qu est pas simple puisque
on a les pions qui gêne un peu donc le
jeu en fait la pression et besson et
noir ont gagné c'est très chaud ici sur
pc matérialiser sur bessengue le centre
blanquer fort donc la nouveauté d'un
vente pour l'instant l'air de marcher au
prix d'un pion quand même au prix d'un
pion
on a une position blanche qui est
vraiment plus facile à jouer facile à
jouer mais pour un tram ni qu'un c'est
pas un problème côté noir
oui pour une chronique voilà ouais c'est
pas grave ça delà on a un taux pas l'un
sans peut-être commence à se dire qu'il
est un petit peu gêné
voilà reste dans son style de jeu dans
son style de jeu y palois rouvrir pour
lui on peut dire que la non double
bonhomme en fait ils essaient de jouer
contre qui conjugue topalov goethe
empêche de jouer et actif
ouais et justes aux mises sous pression
et en plus topalov qui a l'habitude de
jouer maintenant la catalane avec les
blancs a l'impression de jouer contre
lui-même
oui il fallait qu'il joue contre son
ouverture que voilà c'est ça ou même le
piège absolu c'est bien vu deux de vichy
attendre alors tous rêvent d un rallye
comme celle là a noté un col et noir
pour peuvent pas venir sur la magnifique
case d3 qui protégeait pas recyclables
parce qu'il ya le cavalier scène qui
prend la joue simple sinon ça serait une
belle case évidemment hélas en mettant
cette heure-là on menace d'exploser le
centre noir et regardez surtout l'idée
c'est que de menacer de faire sauter
pioncer 6 parce que si le c6 tombe le b
septembre et donc le c4 aussi tout on
voit là et puis la position blanche est
écrasante à ce moment là et c'est un peu
ce qui va se passer on qu'il faut savoir
trouver des coûts côté noir c'est la
grande difficulté à l'ouverture donc là
on a alors d'ailleurs dans cette idée
petit recul énorme depuis joué f6 ici
nos possibilités de jouer les psy ce
simplement si lecavalier soir par
exemple on sait qu'à ouais pourquoi pas
pour venir en 3 serait bientôt trois
donc on peut envisager ça mais le
problème c'est que on perd mais
cavaliers detroit avait comme des
cavaliers quand la main et pas facile à
déloger ce cavalier
oui c'est une idée hein c'est vrai que
f6 sort était plus auraient pu être joué
un rôle très bon alors tombe à l'eau
choisi fou au 8 mai qui rouge ou encore
une pièce qui a déjà joué bon c'est la
tour et ont fermé en plus on n'aime pas
trop un tour enfermé comme ça bon
maintenant
voilà alors et c'est là que c'est pas un
coût de développement alors vraiment
retraire l'avantagé que 4 ou 8 o'clock
sans doute c'est de contrôler la poussée
des 5 avec la dame alors ils pensaient
les vitesses je pensais l'éviter aof
voilà il s'est dit je vais mettre une
pièce de plus sur la taxe des pions ça
va peut-être calmer un peu les blancs
mais non pas du tout des scènes quand
même voilà à ce moment-là a choisi à
nantes de prendre toutes les initiatives
à son compte et de d'ouvrir le jeu un
sachant que regardez bien le nombre de
pièces noires qui sont sur la huitième
ranger c'est impressionnant alors
qu'est-ce qui serait serait passé par
exemple sur pions alors voyez un décès
mais on s'aidera rios regardez donc puis
on prend des 5 c'est parce qu'à jouer
non c'est parce que je tape aller à la
menace ils n'ont s'est prononcée si cb
scène qui saute et si b 5 slots et 80
sont est vrai à tous aux employés
étaient très vite et vous attaquez les
bases des chaînes de pions en
l'occurrence ici c'était le pion ces six
ans on sait pas talentueux aussi ce
qu'on attaque est ici mais la firme
saisi verture et on a le fou regarde et
qui est toujours là en embuscade
donc là on donnerait des en fait en
donnerait la puissance aux pièces
blanches et dont on jouerait contre soi
même donc dans cette variante est pas et
pas jouable imaginons f60 pour chasser
le cavalier bas on peut directement
prendre les pions
prendre avec ses 6 ans parce que l'on
regardé l'idée c'est que sur d'un
programme par exemple tout reprend dames
jeudi un peu n'importe quoi si on prend
le pion au sel
regardez on joue ces sept mais
tranquillement et puis on va on va faire
d'abord regarder on attaque la tour on
attaque le cavalier avec le pion est
aussi au menu de la convention et aux
menaces là donc voilà tout de suite ça
se termine dans un bain de sang en faire
partie encore une fois cette partie côté
noir abbas à une partie chronicles yen
il faut pas faut pas faire n'importe
quoi il ne peut pas pousser il faut
faire des petits mouvements faut
attendre et c'est ce qu'a fait
d'ailleurs pour l'instant topalov à la
dinde et 6 oui mais là il est déjà sous
pression alors c'est si les siens il
tient quand même mal mais il essaie
d'éviter voilà s'il prend une première
fois en fait il libère le potentiel du
fou j'ai deux s'ils laissent les blancs
prendre mais le fou g2 est bloqué par
son propre piège donc c'est un délicate
encore mais pour l'instant topalov tiens
ça tient à mener 6 tient et c'est moins
dangereux que deux venant de prendre
combien de le revoir et on peut pas
ouvrir effectivement qu'à belgique 4 à
leur cou ou malades comme on l'a dit
c'est un peu la vie des conducteurs
qu'elle g4 on va pouvoir venir un ou
trois est protégé et aussi rajouter de
la pression et relais sur ses cartes et
stéphane on menace quelque chose d'un
peu terrible aux échecs c'est de jouer
e5 opoku prochain et de pousser derrière
en suède le pion des en d6 alors
imaginons un coût des noirs je ne sais
pas passifs alors nous imaginons à six
voies l'apprenons
si ce temps là immédiatement nous à
bourg est envisagée au 5
le 5 est gagnant 1 tout de suite alors
la dame et il devrait quitter par
exemple lancé sèche voilà et puis on
positionne que je dessine des six assez
horrible ça fait alors la voilà on les
maintient tout
ça peut être possible menace des cinq et
on a quand même des pions très très fort
ici
voilà une possibilité ouverte il faut
faire attention c'est une possibilité
c'est pas forcément le mieux mais pas
mieux mais c'est la menace principale
c'est quand même nous narrer 5 un livre
on ouvre la position donc dame c5
alors dans ces cinq là sur scène
simplement il n'y a pas d' attaques de
danic je reprends des 5 et 6 ans que là
je récupère points contre le pion
central fort donc là les blancs
finalement vont rapatrier leurs
cavaliers ans le 3 31 continuer à
protéger et toujours avoir une pression
sur cette case sur cette case décès
alors à noter quand même attention que
le coût qualité 3d mais possible oui
cette fois ci les insatiables
c'est pour l'instant un bon alors une
petite ce qui se passerait sur calais
détruire l'intérêt de carrier détroit
évidemment c'est que sa bouche
l'action de la dame les 2es de la tour
et c'était possible je crois que c'était
possible effectivement de jouer mais bon
la priorité peut-être des noirs c'est de
terminer leur développement on a un
cavalier qui joue pas il ya simplement
la merise ans et 6 voilà en train de
voir parce que là c'est la reprise en c6
ensuite b5 saute et on voit qu'on a deux
cavaliers à l'attack de ses carnets en
saucisses et 4,7 lecavalier ton prix
voilà mais ça fait voilà c'est pas bon
et il ya une priorité quand même c'est
de développement donc développé on
développe pour lancer à l'automne et on
envie de jouer mais un peu des 8 et sans
lever définitivement 2
de cette diagonale pénible ah oui cette
diagonale en or c'est l'heure pour pour
un an de faire des bruits des processus
et leurs parce que c'est des scènes qui
est en prise voilà regardez ici
imaginons fou prend 6,6
eh bien ça serait pas terrible terrible
puisque on ferait simplement apprendre
vaisselle fou prend des cinq et on peut
choisir la de l'or dans le réalise
on peut aussi prendre directement
maintenant le pion en c4 et après jouer
la tour c1 après les essayer sur un c4
et on peut jouer simplement de torah
c'est au tour efficiente ou celle là où
laure et où tour à ses seins simplement
laissé là à mon goût et par exemple un
c'est aussi jouable peut-être dans
peut-être trois c1 ici là et on récupère
et on récupère d'une part on appris le
pion c4i les problèmes qu'on sort avec
une position supérieure côté bah oui
parce que sinon tu sors évidemment il ya
le dames derrière donc un clouage jeu
mortel qui suffit pour récupérer avec
une position meilleure puisque on va
avoir le fou qui est magnifique le pion
à scène qui est peut-être on peut faire
avec blake deux colonnes contrôlé par
les blancs avec donc une ligne
voilà un avantage du traditionnel
dynamique voilà tout à fait donc on
finirait en fait encore dans une bonne
position côté blanc donc c'est là c'est
pour ça qu'en fait on voit que 1
topalov a choisi des packs à reprendre
le pion à 4 ans qui est plus logique
voilà il simplifie d'une autre façon
voilà c'est fini cette façon cavalia bon
voilà ça y est donc là ça justifie
évidemment ce pion donc c'est toute
l'idée des carriers à trois qui faisait
pression sont baissiers sont ces cas le
cavalier qui est à la bande regarder
comment en actifs
ces pièces de façon efficace le cavalier
la bande bien reprendre le pion donc en
s'activant en visant le centre alain
cazorla et où on protégerait c6 de
nouveau on a taxé 5 au passage et la
tour un attaque à 4 moi j'aime beaucoup
ça fait mais c'est un honneur de jouer
ouais faut prendre ces 6 donc on reprend
côté noir le pion c6 et puis voilà les
blancs continuent leur développement
avec un coût qui est logique
là bas c'est assez on profite du fait
que la dame est mal placée voilà la dame
est sous la menace est évidemment de la
tour c 1 les bleus ont toujours un pion
de moins mais c'est des pions doublé
c'est ça donc c'est pas grave
donc faut maîtriser parce qu'il a un qui
soit 1 ou 2 à 8 soit collage et on
remarque aussi stéphane que la position
des cavaliers noirs n'est pas n'est pas
très bonne
douala il sur la colonne b mais rassure
la colombe et je ne contrôle pas la case
qui est à l'extérieur de l'échiquier
nous élançons sinon c'est pas trop ce
qu'ils font sur ce côté je suis là et
les rincer poney carrier la bande avait
gardé un deux trois quatre cases
contrôlée par ce cavalier à 6 contre eux
évidemment du côté du cavalier dix ans
quand le 5 arles et ses cadres entre 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 cases et voilà il rien d'un
griot exactement donc vous voyez la
différence de d'éclat et ses cavaliers
en plus alors on va noter quand même
quelque chose regarder un deux trois
quatre ces pièces allèles dame
oui donc on a quand même droit et de ce
côté là seuls ceux dont il est le seul
en cours l'instant la rente âge matériel
des pièces blanches sur les lois n'est
pas tout de suite significative d'au
revoir qu'à nantes va réussir à les
rendre actif de ce côté là oui on va
regarder et en plus alors là topaloff
est sans doute au cou horrible alors je
pense que là c'est une erreur c'est
quand même et on se demande d'où sort ce
coup oui h 6 alors bon un coup peut-être
s'il savait pas trop quoi jouer il
disait bon je vois pas de coups mais je
vais dire à mon blanc à toi de jouer je
me prépare la fameuse petite fenêtre
petite fenêtre de ce match mais
heureusement atteint certes ce coup on a
l'impression que c'est une grosse perte
de temps et c'est même pire que ça qu'on
allait voir
alain dejoux calais des six alors
attention attaques de la dame
il ya le fond derrière alors c'est pas
très grave tant que la dame reste au
contact c'est pas grave mais attention
parce qu'on peut envisager après les
sacrifices de tous en c6 dépliant qui
pousse en cinq avec le fou g2 qui
attaquent cavallaro derrière voilà alors
on si on revient deux minutes sur le
coup
si ce qui nous paraît bizarre stéphane
là on aurait peut-être pu envisager un
coup comme d'hab hausse est tout
simplement bien sûr venir voilà côté
comme tel signal et louis leroy qui est
un polar zoo les empêcher l'a7 vis-à-vis
remettra d'art du côté de l'aileron au
cas où il puisse se passer des trucs de
ce côté là et après activer les tours
centre tout simplement on voit pas très
bien pourquoi
topalov à voulait jouer ce coup à ses 5
et qui affaiblit donc du coup on va voir
derrière
oui
on va voir on va dire la menace directe
de la dame à la rue de calais des
systèmes peut pas revenir aux recettes
du coup à la matière et nous attaquer à
la dame voilà donc les premières on va
dire une première conséquence de ce
couac c'est ça qui est assez néfaste
côté noir s'appuie comme gilles le fou
ne veut se retrouver un peu moindre le
seul etc
c'est pareil c'est un peu chaud alors
soit c'est damas est pardon ouais alors
l'idée de topalov sur damas est c'est de
garder apparemment un oeil sur cette
diagonale dont ça c'est une chose mais
aussi de contrôler la travée raeren
saria par une pièce canada est en
défense mais n'y a pas d' attaque
directe on voit que les blancs quand
même gagné la bataille du centre
ils ont un pion central contre 0 l'a
incarné des 600 puits ce qui est bien
placé dans le camp adverse donc qui
contrôle la colonne des parfaitement
dans la colonne séisme dessus ouais
l'ouverture a été très favorable au plan
sur ces les blancs sont au niveau des
pièces sont clairement ils ont - messi
auteur d'un doublé comme la maison
l'activité en contrepartie est là alors
là le coup alors que n'a pas du tout
parfois en s'assoyant ce soit quelque
chose qu'il est fait pour pour tenter
l'adversaire c'est possible aussi ça
peut hélas on le voit la trêve à nantes
est magnifique avec g4 alors qu'on très
beau alors double idée pour ce club j4
pourquoi pas un visage et un sacrifice
en 1,6 échec au roi suivi de dame prend
avec un roi qui est tenu deux pions pour
la pièce plus la possibilité pourquoi
pas de maths et en ayant calculé qu'on
peut par exemple ramener une tour alors
on ne peut pas travailler si ce n'est
pour l'instant dans une errance sng
cinqs afrique ou h5 s'affairaient
quasiment un match dans ces conditions
la deuxième idée pour le câble et g4
évidemment c'est de venir sur la case
gsm euseigne par mon attaquant le food
ou 6 et 6 et aussi attaquant f cette
voie là
kippen a une case de sacrifices mais une
belle position pour un cavalier au
centre comme celle souligné tout à
l'heure avec donc un nombre très
imposant de case control et 8,15 quand
on est aux 130 bien sûr donc et puis
ramené les pièces complémentaires on va
dire pour le matin la dame est tout à
fait un donc là cavalier g4 s'impose est
magnifique mais dans un local des cadets
alors mais qui n'est permis enfin qu'il
a autant de force que parce que kato
parfois jouer super six qui est une
cible on décide presse une invitation a
sacrifié et tu vas y est tout est prêt
pour les blancs pour sacrifier je ne ne
pas sacrifier la wii mais c'est presque
ce serait presque alors on peut
effectivement mais c'est le paradoxe de
topalov en fait il peut tu peux jouer
des parties fabuleuse et puis commettre
des bourdes infâme et la wii ch 6 voiles
alors il a perdu le fil 1 on a peur des
filles concrètement il savait plus quoi
faire et est seul dans ses positions
j'insiste encore seul dans ses positions
de la catalane avec les noirs seul
gramme nigra mais parce que ramener qui
a le génie de savoir ne rien faire oui
et ça c'est important rien faire de
façon intelligente de voile alors à
faire de façon intelligente aux échecs
c'est pas donné à tout le monde
on voit bien que la hache hisser sur
pierce n'a pas l'échec rien faire au
sens large opération
moins intelligent ah c'est vrai aussi
mais bon là on voit très bien causer
chez qu'il ya un maître du savoir
on va dire pondéré ses coûts et attendre
c'est pas topaloff alors on voit la
suite donc tour à des huit alors
magnifiques lots restants la suite enfin
là pour l'instant développement de tours
a redit mais pas l'autre tour parce
qu'il sent qu'il ya besoin de matériel
pour des varois et il amène celle là qui
en plus ils ont envie de se sortir de
quand même toujours de cette diagonale
toujours extrêmement pénible et c'est
l'heure pour attendre alors regardez on
y va magnifique coup plus beau de la
partie mais perd permis par cette
bizarre là rien à faire une erreur
robien qui est une erreur car vallée
prend 1,6 de hollande magnifique
alors là en fait le tigre de madras sort
ses griffes oui parce que c'est le
surnom d'un institut madrague voilà et
bondy et là on va avoir une saute sur sa
proie de bondy c'est harry ses griffes
alors attention à la maison ne fait pas
ça à tous les coups un calcul est quand
même bien ce que la saison risque de
faire mal
oui si je préfère le dire pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent près
de chez eux
attention on ne le fait pas à chaque
coup on ne fait pas chaud n'est là il ya
un calcul fabuleux on voit tout de suite
d'ailleurs alors déjà il ya deux pions
où est la pièce qui n'est pas rien déjà
voilà un retour sur investissement
immédiat immédiat on va dire avec une
position aussi et le roi noir qui
totalement total à l'ouest voilà
exactement qui final vous regardez voilà
toutes ces cases au tour sont faibles il
suffirait maintenant alors on peut pas
le faire tout de suite mais il suffirait
de ramener une tour on peut imaginer le
coup regardez comme c'est qu on libère
et anjou tour c4 et c'est fini et voilà
un stage et quatre matches aux tours h4
fut bien mais là c'est un peu d'idées la
suite c'est un peu l'idée de l'âge de m6
d'auto palois la voilà donc c'est ce
qu'on disait tout à l'heure la dame
assiette avec hunter regardez regardez
regardez comme c'est beau ce genre de
coups latéral faut toujours avoir à
l'idée quand même parce que si le calcul
est mal fait ce simple coup peut suffire
il est tout
velléités adverses oui parce que
simplement la dame revient et puis va
essayer de s'échanger contre la dame
blanche de la cie des dames s'échange à
plus d'attaqué après il y en a dans les
caisses
voilà on a noté une piètre août contre
les pièces face à la comptabilité à
gotham wayne se rend compte qu'il manque
une pièce a été lent donc zéro la
totalité bête et méchant à ouidah énorme
et c'est la défense c'est le boulot
c'est le bilan je dirais brut de brut
ah oui mais côté noir c'est ce qu'il
faut avec il faut pas permettre
évidemment le développement de l'
attaque donc alors et la magnifique à
regarder les noms n'ont pas le temps ou
c'est exactement ce qu'on vient de dire
la regarder pourquoi parce que si les
noms reviennent ici simplement en
échange et simplement je prends aussi 6
et après ton cas tout reprend j'ai
récupéré l'avantagé matériel sauf que
allez les blancs mais j'ai quasiment de
plus en plus des pionniers en plus
qu'ils sont tous tous faibles donc on a
quasiment trois ou quatre tournois mais
là ça se fait qu'on a nous et c'est
archi archi foutu et là on voit de
regarder la pièce de plus il faut que
les noirs garner pièce de plus faut
essayer côté noir d'échanger un tout ce
qui est possible d'échanger
oui et puis colmater les brèches parce
que là en ouvrant par cinq les
diagonales et aussi les rangées on va
dire les colonnes pour les tours ça va
être chaud on l'a on a basculé dans la
tactique et on est dans la veine des
grands
en fait dans le jeu tactique alors on va
voir la suite qui est magnifique
donc faut plonger de dà nang ella perdre
et ils échangent et là on alors là on
pour on aurait pu envisager pourquoi pas
un tour ses quatrains très bien c'est
pas ce qu'a fait un nom mais c'est tout
à fait envisageable c'est un visage
annoncé 4 avec l'idée simplement toucher
4 et seimat
même si dame g7 ont fait d'un prendre ça
aurait tout changé 4 est tout à fait
envisageable mais là en fait on voit
très bien stéphane que la poussée du
pion messiaen permettre en fait la
continuation d'une attaque à la main
fait ont fait eux prend un f6 voilà le
problème si c'est parce que là l'idée
c'est que si on a déjà récupéré des
pions pour la pièce si en plus après six
échecs on récupère une qualité non
seulement en attaque continue parce que
le roi est un état neuf années en plus
matériellement on a très largement
équilibré les affaires et même une
attaque cas qui n'ont quasiment terminée
quoi je suis donc là les noirs sont un
peu désespérée dans cette position le
seul coup de défense qu'il trouve alors
il y aurait pu tenter notre coin wink 81
à damas cette voie là on pense à ce coup
bien sûr pour essayer d'arrêter
complètement l'attaquent
dans ce cas la dame g5 échec ou un sweat
droit je suis toujours pareil le même
coup et on arrive à poser toutes ces 40
latour ans et cap qui va aller en h4
mena et de venir voilà je garde avec la
dame cloud est aussi adams hamas emad
voilà donc on passe tout de suite la
tour et là on est dans du lourd puisque
pièces lourdes
on ne pouvait pas trouver cette défense
suffisante pour pour les noirs dont il
ya aussi six tours j'ai vite qu'ils
étaient qui était envisageable regarder
ça alors là il ya un matin de 4 qui est
magnifique car l'alliage cèdres chênes
alors ton g8 c'est intéressant parce que
surtout rage 4 évidemment je fais tout
reprendre
et après tout reprendre tout en
améliorant della en fait sacrifice
deuxième sacrifice de cavaliers échec
landed on est obligé de reprendre
voila voila on gagne le temps pour
donner les chèques tour h4 richesse
voilà donc la dame obligé de se mettre
devant son roi voilà et simplement le
m'attend 2 arrive par un tour prend des
8 par exemple pour preuve cette voie la
plus rapide est un symbole at on le sait
alors pour europe 1 entourée damascène
matt une
demat magnifique super regarder le roi
qu'est prix peut pas revenir en irak aux
bateaux et angers 7 à cause du pion
seimat c'est magnifique
très bon matt de coin avec un sacrifice
de cavaliers donc voyez comme c'est
chaud dans cette position les coudes
défense sont extrêmement difficiles à
trouver
et tout ça provient en fait de la
poussée du plan au sein de tout à
l'heure il ya qui sacrifie encore en
pièce deux pièces de moins mais regardez
les deux pièces cas c'est lui qui en ont
elles sont là c'est à dire que la
compensation noir n existe pas aller
totalement du jeu les statiques
effectivement les statiques et en du jeu
là la dynamique du côté du sacrifice
elle est beaucoup plus forte
exactement donc là c'est pas une partie
du tout matérialiste mais une partie on
va dire d'attac un dynamique côté blu
ray c'est magnifique aux énoncés
c'est vraiment de la belle ouvrage comme
monde et on a on a vraiment du dynamisme
sur l'échiquier
alors on voit la suite taupe alors on
prend ce cavalier qui est hyper
dangereux alors voilà la menace est
aussi il essaye d'être simplement
simplement ces magnifiques parce qu'un
homme reprend simplement et s'il reprend
le fou mais je veux dire même
matériellement il a
tour contre tours ici tour contre deux
cavaliers mais avec plein qui ont de
plus et un endroit totalement aux
fraises voilà surtout à la stéphane
parce qu'on a on a le tour c4 qui va
arriver sur l'un de ces quatre carrés en
voit pas comment les noirs pour parer
les menaces de maths donc
donc il faut pas surtout que total
allait se fout donc ça ici là ce fou
même la taille elle ment c'est foutu
donc garder l'avantagé matériel qui peut
lui espérer bateau ni evra je râle un
sauvetage il joue feu car voilà il veut
le ramener peut-être en achète à bella
il veut bien sûr revenir en sept manches
et un peu la tacc l'attaquent blanche
simplement les noirs jouent le
magnifique et très simple tour prend 1,6
à leur double menace
oui tout reprend fou évidemment et
deuxième menace pas des moindres tour
cette attaque la dame et menaces matt
puisque la tour intercepterait la
chanson de la salade à boulemane donc
double menace quasiment imparable alors
topalov je trouve encore un coup
cavaliers detroit alors l'idée de
cahiers des trois c - d'attaquer la tour
c'est un que de menacer d'avoir une
contre menace pour preuve deux échecs
masse qui serait matin d'ailleurs donc
cela on revoit en regarde par exemple
pour cet art dès ses matches
c'est directement m'attend un coup donc
puisque le fou et 4 empêche le roi de
bouger donc faut faire attention il ya
quand même une menace noir mais qui est
pas qui est pas difficile apparaît
simplement tour ces deux d'un an donc la
deuxième tour est à fond elle protège là
tranquillement et amena ce concept est
tout reprend fous existent toujours
appuyé même surtout temps fou il ya
encore tout rejet 4 derrière gênant ça
ça arrive de partout donc là la menace
de menthe et paré et on est toujours
dans une position très délicate côté
noir donc comment comment à ravaler la
pollution est perdue en fait alors on va
voir quand même topalov essaye encore
quelques coups en europe s'est perdue il
ya beaucoup de variantes évidemment fort
et tout voir mais on peut pas tout voir
mais on va simplement suivre la partie
damages 7 bon ben on essaie d'échanger
des dames quand on est comme moi même
problème d'attaqué évidemment essayer
d'échanger les dames puisque la taxe va
être plus légère plus facile à supporter
coincé sous c'est parfois donc pas
suffisant alors mais en jouant dans
machete déjà regardé déjà pouf d'amazon
de toute manière des pièces au passage
il est temps mes habillons mais il ya
pire laquelle en procédant processus de
sauvegarde de survie le pauvre topaloff
regardez ce que je joue à nantes alors
là l'idée c'est qu'à nantes veut garder
sa dame ne met pas être obligés
d'échangés dont qui jouait cet échec
magnifique parce que regarder si la dame
prend la dame noire prend à regarder que
font les noirs que ça me leblanc
simplement tour kung fu voilà on a la
menaçant en g4 toujours là menaçant g4
quasiment imparable lève le pied au f2
est toujours protégé avec la tour c 2
donc ya pas de menace de dang tran et
donc on a toujours cette menace qui est
très très fort très puissante et et qui
est et qui gagnent entre tout simplement
est donc impossible donc
ça comptait le ramassage aussi des duos
qui est possible enfin c'est quand même
assez horrible donc tout reprend 1,4
pour 3,4 pardon
non on a dit en fait on est dans la
vallée des trois tours ces deux dames
âge sept mois la machette cet échec
voilà autres coups possibles pour les
normands pourriez envisager roi par
exemple
alex est simplement touriste ouais là ça
va être la bonne et puis ça va être mat
et d'un prince suivi de maths voilà donc
par exemple gauche ici pour éviter leur
aide directe d'emprunts fuite échec roi
17 et simplement la tour où daniel
ozanne le match matt puisque rappelez
vous toujours cette course et 2 qui à la
fois jouer un rôle d'attaquant et de
défenseurs magnifique mais super se
tourne donc tout est utilisé alors à
plein c'est vraiment le thème de la
partie l'activité des pièces blanches et
dernière solution tout reprend f7 par
exemple l'échec
voilà maintenant deux suivis de touré
fuite et c'est matt voilà ta d'amour
avec la tour avec la tossée parie donc
sur f7 il ya guère que dans le premier
set pour prendre quatre qui tient à peu
près et
c'est d'ailleurs ce que fait la taupe a
lancé voilà il a vu donc immédiatement
la menace et comment on peut parier je
pense qu'il ya pas de solution alors
imaginez un peu comme dame g7 par
exemple voilà essayons alors que pour
ton jouer dans cette voie là tout
simplement tour échec est effectivement
et après on voit que les tours vont
terminer le travail puisque alors sur
alors surtout surtout regarder surtout
rêve s'être simplement tour g4 et la
dame est cloué voilà si le roi vient sur
la colonne h eh bien il se prend un tour
h4 et faut donner la dame et ses maths
c'est fénélon dernière solution possible
c'est simplement d'un médecin on est
simplement ont fait regarder tour j'ai
quatre échecs rouages cette voie là et
on poursuit encore dames quatre échecs
roi je suis de forcer sinon ce fait si
on vient à 6 on va se faire mater par
tour hkd
et puis bon c'est terminé on bond en d4
on peut suivre la variante quand même
des regrets mais on voit pas comment les
noirs peuvent résister à la machine et
regardez le coup qui tue tout ça ce voit
là s'il va s'attarder sur dame prend
dames on a le match du couloir on est
encore matin c'est quand même horrible
un exemple on aurait situation fait
tactique est complètement perdue côté
noir et pourquoi il reste des pièces le
rendait cette pièce elle joue pas à
celle là elle est allée me à moitié
active j'ai envie de dire et le roi ont
regardé une simplement des attaques de
damer tour contre au roi tout nu
voyez comme c'est comme si horrible oui
alors donc topalov à jouer je crois de
f5 voilà ta meuf sains et ils
abandonnent sur tours 7 ce que là il ya
plus de y'a plus de défense la menace
c'est matt vraiment comment parer mathis
ebay on peut difficilement alors si on
fait d'un 9,6 on a maintenant un set
donc voila c'est direct mais si on fait
tout tours fc est simplement c'est
l'autre tour il ya et puis on sera
obligé et on fait quand même matt voilà
on arrive dans toutes les positions à
être mat en cinq six coups et d'ailleurs
c'était une question qu'on a posés à nos
lecteurs dans cette position finale quel
est le mat et cinq coups en france un
couple maximum le symbole exercice à
ouvrage wigan
oui parce que ça fait travailler de
calcul par ses courbes l'anjou et
d'ailleurs c'est au noir c'est au noir
même dans cette position donc quel que
soit le coût des noirs le match mais en
cinq coups sûrs cette position dame f5
les blancs jouent et gagnent tour cet or
cette fois les sept ya pas de défense
puisque si on mène à un tour en fait
c'est l'autre tour qui peuvent venir
faire échec
la dame de contrôle et h7 puisque c'est
ma tâche est aussi c'est maintenant
j'essaie tout de suite la menace ne peut
pas jouer la dame
et si on joue maintenant il ya un autre
nom et puis arrière pas de demeurer
c'est magnifique
cette partie stéphane très belle partie
donc ça c'était la quatrième partie donc
à nan men
deux victoires à une en fait c'est la
dent qu'un autre vient de prendre
l'avantagé dans le match puisque je
réalise un deuxième gain avec deux et
demi contre un ennemi à topal enfin deux
victoires une nulle contre une victoire
simplement et une nulle côté topaloff
est deux fois on peut le dire avec la
catalane alors oui deux fois et là deux
fois donc on peut se demander c'est un
cauchemar pour topalov a total of n'est
pas masochiste d'avoir rejoué une
catalane après avoir perdu la deuxième
partie quoi donc moi je ne peux pas
difficilement il pour jouer un peu ben
il peut jouer tout simplement un gambit
d'amis peut il peut varier en fait
l'ouverture sur ces 4 il peut en fait
ouais mais que d'autres pas l'os et
ouais c'est tout joué un set aux mains
donc mais je pense que son ego l'a
poussé à dire je vais rejouer la
catalane différemment on a vu au
cinquième coup un fourbe et 4 1
l'avarié mais il n'a pas trouvé la
solution face à un à nantes qui s'était
bien préparé avec le 10ème cook avalé un
à trois attaquants les pions mais ça
m'est difficile il faudrait que je ne
sais pas moi une grande faim d'autres
comme ça parce que qu'est ce qui peut
faire alors là grünfeld c'est quand même
assez risqué mais
juste dans son tempérament effectivement
de jouer une brune fade du coup il salue
sortirait de sa préparation alors voila
voila et puis sachant qu'il a joué
topalov à jouer
disons déjà de catalan on peut se dire
qu'ils s'étaient ils s'étaient préparés
sur la catalane donc il a quand même
dans son sac pas maj des outils de foot
qui s'est pris une déculottée paraiba il
avait dû travailler le sujet mais voilà
apparemment mais un cours particulier
pas grave ni oui les jeunes il a voulu
montrer qu'il avait qu'il allait
dépasser le maître et la non à deux fois
par deux fois il a il a failli sur une
catalane alors intéressant on va on va
suivre
essentiellement la partie les parties
comme la sixième pour voir si il retente
avec les noirs la diège alain bien sûr
ça peut être intéressant de voir s'il a
pu améliorer les choses depuis
alors sachant qu topalov or les noirs
deux fois puisque à la 6e ils auront les
noirs et la 7e
c'est la deuxième moitié du match et on
inverse les couleurs c'est un peu comme
au tennis et voilà on change un nouvel
ami d'enfance de terrain commun voilà
voilà donc ce qui fait que le passé la
moitié du match c'est de nouveau ses
fans qui démarre avec des blancs puisque
cette première moitié c'est démarrer
parties impaires donc merci philippe
bain pour des commentaires sur ce grand
match à nantes topalov donc on te
retrouve tous les jours sur chelsea
stratégie.com avec les news funny people
du jeu d'échecs
exactement évidemment des liens toujours
vers des modèles tv oui mais tu es de la
musique de la musique de la musique
alors le match et squeeze à le mari
chuck molloy tout un tas de choses fun
s'amuser tous les jours et
à aux échecs en soit de chez soi soi
quand on rentre du travail soit où il
travaille la première chose à faire si
ce match est sorti trop tranquille avant
de rentrer dans des choses bien sûr
d'ailleurs j'en profite pour dire que
sur facebook on est sur facebook est
tout aussi oui on peut aller voir les
nouvelles sur twitter aussi vous voulez
lui ou les réseaux qui vous avez un
portable vous regardez sur twitter vous
abonner à que ces stratégies vont avoir
les news merci philippe merci à toi
stéphane à bientôt sur des mandats télé
merci nous est fidèle et puis avait on
va suivre que ce match pour les
prochaines parties de ce championnat du
monde
allende topalov au revoir au revoir